freeways themselves are moving along
okay but the 215 getting off towards the
airport and also on Paradise trying to
get through the connector tunnels that's
not going to happen Metro Police
confirmed that about a half hour ago
Southbound on the paradise south of
Russell before you get into the airport
connector tunnels a fatal crash so the
folks getting off the 215 they are
allowing you through the tunnel but
instead of going up onto Paradise you're
being diverted off towards Russell Road
southbounders we'll take a look at this
live picture southbound drivers this is
that fatal crash southbound Paradise at
Russell Road here being diverted off at
Terminal 3 there is a way to wiggle your
way through to the 215 instead of using
this the airport connector tunnel that
thousands of people use so just follow
the signs but plan on big delays and
come in the other way Northbound again
you're gonna have to work your way
through towards Russell in the side
streets the signs are posted you will be
able to get through